me me me me me me me me me me me me me
ma-ma-ma-ma-ma
testing testing pilot to Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier it was sunny and all
of a sudden dark clouds are coming over
the horizon pilot to Bombardier I could
not see anything as it safe to land
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] if you got New England
given the four and a half and the 48 and
a half on the over forget about it
forget about it it's a beautiful day to
be alive the birds are chirping the
sun's out are you [ __ ] kidding me or
what it's Super Bowl Sunday and I don't
give a Frenchman's [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
doing that things to do and people to
see but I want you people to enjoy it
smoke your reefer I know the Super Bowl
three hours away but we don't give a
[ __ ] we start right now because this is
how we do it we get down you know I'm
saying anyway there's not a [ __ ]
clock there's not a [ __ ] cloud in the
sky it's about 87 degrees here in sunny
Los Angeles you don't mean looking
tip-top Magoo feeling tip-top Magoo my
ballsack has piloted my [ __ ] is
sparkling and I'm a new [ __ ] man I
got a couple [ __ ] out for brains and
me and who the [ __ ] gonna stop you you
know I'm saying I just wanted to touch
base with you and make sure my [ __ ]
shirt I'm with you you're with me and
they want to be with us you understand
me
they could all suck our dick it's us
against the world we but at it's as they
[ __ ] won my soldiers out there we
gots Church soldiers everywhere the
hallways and see [ __ ] is we are [ __ ]
people and [ __ ] Montana Snake River
Hyde I got let me tell you something you
slip up the church you'll find your
[ __ ]
anyway you got the [ __ ] Eagles I
don't know about nothing but I do know
one thing
[ __ ] Tom Brady dumped a pregnant
chick and hooked up with the Brazilian
anybody who dumped dumps a pregnant
chick I don't know what to tell you get
him saying he went against his Catholic
[ __ ] thing he went deep into the
immigrant mentality because only
immigrants do that type of [ __ ] you
ain't sucking the right kind of dick you
gotta go you know I'm saying but anyway
who gives a [ __ ] about that it's all
about us as a celebration remember in
[ __ ] Goodfellas four guys was
it's a celebration it's a party what
[ __ ] part I'm dead dick and
everybody's suck but hey that's a
different type of party the party I'm
talking about is even know you got the
Super Bowl on all these [ __ ] are
jumping up and down we're still going
[ __ ] deep we still do our 22 push-ups
we still do our [ __ ] golf and we
still [ __ ] write down what the [ __ ]
destruction we're gonna lay on these
[ __ ] this week cuz nothing stops
us let all these [ __ ] hahahaha
in my day the best day to rob was on the
Superbowl cuz everybody's watching
football somebody's house I got two
hours to [ __ ] make bacon go through
your [ __ ] so always remember that while
you're watching the game at somebody's
house somebody's casing your [ __ ]
joint anyway
Joey what's with their beat let me tell
you what I'm smoking today I'm smoking
something but I'm death when you got a
[ __ ] container with two different
color [ __ ] tops on it you know you're
going deep into the murky waters you
understand me I'm gonna start eating
edibles here in about 30-40 minutes I'm
gonna do a little workout a little light
workout just to get the blood moving and
I'm saying I'm 55 in two [ __ ] weeks
don't forget why there's an extra show
in Denver Thursday night at ten o'clock
do not forget the ice house is sold out
on Saturday the 17th but we had a
birthday show the 18th at the [ __ ]
comedy store belly room all-star lineup
and that's it and that's that brother I
just want to get together with you
[ __ ] to let you know it's time
to swing they can give it our bubble gum
we're getting into the February months
while all these [ __ ] Gentiles are
worried about Valentine's Day [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them you worried about [ __ ]
breaking out making your thing making
your own [ __ ] pad you like Tony in 84
you want to set your own markers get him
saying and enforce it
anyway I'm feeling good I'm looking good
feeling good looking good Billy Ray
anyway where is your [ __ ] mr.
big-time pimp didn't I tell you the
phone and limo was busted that's right
I'm dropping Trading Places on you 1983
Eddie Murphy one of his best [ __ ]
performances you understand me but
anyway we got some podcasts coming at
you this week
to shows and that's it I'm much going on
you know uncle Joey I had to live
day-to-day like no [ __ ] schedule but
I got a schedule you follow me and I
suggest you do the same anyway enjoy the
soup bowl with your families have a
great day today don't let nobody [ __ ]
with you but most importantly while
they're all jumping up and down you're
getting your week together
suit up any son that I maintain and I'm
saying you're thinking about how you
gonna stab my [ __ ] this week are
you gonna break crew this week you got
to write your goals gonna be two
push-ups and you gotta [ __ ] think how
we gonna make it to the next [ __ ]
level it's over
I'm not eating french fries normal what
ends today that's it hey you could be in
worse places y'all here with your uncle
Joey you follow me uncle Joey cares
about you remember when are you
[ __ ] I got in the end that better
day you know what in the end that better
that means an Italian you got nothing
you got nothing when somebody comes up
to you and says you got weed me aunt
that better tan I'm nothin for you both
shout out to my bolder family the mother
[ __ ] loud Ezio's I'll be seeing them
in a few weeks I'm gonna interview
[ __ ] Tony for the podcast we're gonna
let you [ __ ] know our life and
bolder was when I was over there [ __ ]
doing my criminality all those years I'm
not proud of it but it's what happened I
know you're not proud of yourself some
days but you know what it gets better
just believe it write it down you're
gonna become a [ __ ] savage and within
a year or two you'll be a savage and
you're not going to look over your
[ __ ] shoulder no more because in
respect you are a [ __ ] savage you
just didn't get the [ __ ] memo yet you
follow me
[Laughter]
people never get the memo some people
get it
guess what I'm delivering it to your
[ __ ] speedy man look look I kind of
write to your [ __ ] mailbox you're a
[ __ ] Savage don't take [ __ ] from
nobody write your goals down and tell
them what a suck your dick is at the end
it's your world you know I'm saying
they're just [ __ ] visiting [ __ ]
psychic
uncle Joey I love you and remember every
day that didn't get my mother happy now
I look at the wrong californee
doing it copied on the boat hey I said
it it's gonna pass our imports are you I
love you [ __ ] have a great time
with the game and I'll check in with you
later all right I promise you I checked
when you [ __ ] then will get
stoned or snort some [ __ ] xanax
whatever you want to do stay black